sur TF1 vous êtes devenu le couteau
suisse de la chaîne oh bah je suis
devenu la dame qu'on sort une fois par
an de son placard
[Rires]
j'ai fait Danse avec les stars
et puis après j'ai fait mon plus beau
Noël et mes plus belles vacances et
maintenant je suis pour les chats les
missions pour les chats
et après et ben j'ai fait maintenant
j'ai fait une fois par an mes plus
belles vacances voilà moi j'aime bien la
franchise quand on passe au travail
c'est bien de le dire moi j'aime bien
les gens ils aiment pas il y a toujours
des mecs quand ils t'ont interroge des
animateurs ils disent jamais qui sont
placard ou qui sait exactement oui mais
non on est sur des projets je suis sur
un truc avec exactement je me positionne
différemment moi j'ai très envie de
faire de la fiction en fait la vérité
mais tu peux aussi dire que voilà que tu
vas partir de la chaîne plutôt que de
chercher dans la soupe quand il y a
encore mais alors moi je préfère
quelqu'un comme ça bah tu veux que je te
dise moi j'aime bien ce qu'elle a fait
Bernard Montiel ça veut dire qu'elle a
des yox oui mais pourquoi elle est comme
ça Binche parce qu'elle aimerait en
avoir plus et qu'elle est négligée par
la chaîne donc en fait elle s'exprime
parce qu'en fait
tu attaques les mauvaises personnes
la-bas
je vous dis bon ressenti
aussi aux gens qui sont pas dans le
milieu de la télé qu'en fait bah c'est
pas forcément facile qu'elle décide pas
de tout ce qui lui arrive et qu'en fait
bah elle a pas de travail il lui donne
pas de travail il a néglige et il se
foutent un peu de sa tronche elle elle
en demande donc en fait elle s'exprime
et ça montre aux gens que c'est pas si
facile et c'est pas parce qu'on passe
une fois dans l'année à la télé qu'on
gagne sa vie et que et sous contrat
quand même hein
et elle soulève aussi le problème des
femmes à la télé de plus de 50 ans voir
55 ans
mais je pense qu'effectivement c'est la
double peine en fait et le placard et la
femme est à partir d'un certain âge moi
je trouve qu'en plus elle a un talon
bien sûr
on n'a pas l'habitude à la télévision
mais c'est vrai que à l'époque nous à
TF1 on allait parfois des contrats
d'image d'exclus donc la limite que tu
passes pas la télé ou pas
si tu passes plus la télé on te voit
plus on t'oublie quoi rapide il y a plus
il y en a quelques-unes
d'animateur par exemple où ça que vous
aimez beaucoup bah ici sur C8 donc par
exemple moi d'exclusion
[Rires]
c'est toujours le même débat Guillaume
c'est toujours pareil on a l'impression
que ils veulent tous ces gens veulent
que ce soit pour l'éternité
maintenant il faut peut-être qu'elle
charge d'autres projets peut-être en
radio peut-être un truc ailleurs
c'est comme c'est comme faut rester au
journal de 20h pendant des années faut
faire faut faire Julien Julien Lepers là
elle répond et par ailleurs
effectivement elle est sur scène aussi
actuellement
on s'en fout un peu non non Valérie
Damidot s'expose c'est vachement bien en
étant spectacle
qui fait de la télé tu connais qui
tu me connaissais avant de venir
je rajoute un cadeau
[Applaudissements]